SPEAKER 1: We have a lot
to cover with you today.
We have a bunch of really
cool guest speakers
that are going to bring stories.
And we're going to focus today
about speech-to-text and speech
recognition.
So speech-to-text is
part of our conversation
a group of products
in our building
blocks as part of Cloud AI.
We have a very large
portfolio of AI solutions,
all of them pretty much
leading in their space.
So I would definitely
recommend if you have some time
to check out some of
the other sessions
about the other products, a lot
of cool stuff being announced
yesterday and today at Next.
So how many people here were at
our Google Cloud Next session
last year on speech-to-text?
OK, a few of you.
So it's hard to believe, but
last year when we were here,
the product was still in beta.
So we actually only announced
GA just over a year ago
in April 2017, and
long-form recognition.
The product has gone
through so much since then.
We've added 30 new languages.
We're now at 120 languages,
which is mind-boggling,
and a bunch of other features,
like timestamps, punctuation,
and the new models, which
we'll talk about later.
There's two main use
cases that we address--
speech for human-computer
interaction and speech
analytics.
Human-computer
interaction is typically
one person talking
to a computer,
and then a computer
reacting to it--
either voice search, or voice
actions, or things like that.
Speech analytics is
analyzing conversations
between different humans.
It could be in a phone call,
it could be in a meeting.
So we're going to sort of
structure the conversation
today around those
two sets of use cases.
So today, we're introducing four
new beta features, or actually
yesterday--
language ID,
multi-channel recognition,
speaker diarization, and
word-level confidence.
We're going to talk
more about each of them,
so we'll come back to them.
But they all make speech-to-text
much, much more useful
and practical for the various
use cases that it solves.
So let's focus on the
first set of use cases
first, so human-computer
interaction,
when you want to use speech
recognition to power sort
of different apps or solutions.
So there, our new feature
we're introducing for that
is language ID.
So like you can see on the
right on that screenshot,
for Google search, if
you use voice search,
you can select multiple
different languages.
So it's not a radio button.
It's sort of check
boxes, and you
can check as many as you want.
And then when you
speak to it, it
can understand which
language you're talking.
And it recognizes the
transcription in that language.
So we're now making that
available in the API.
You just send multiple
language codes,
we figure out which
one is the right one,
and we return the
transcript in that language.
It works pretty well, but
it's still not perfect.
So if you actually know the
language code in advance,
you're always better
off just supplying it.
But if you don't know
and you have multiple,
it's going to do kind
of a best-efforts job
at figuring out which
language it was.
It's currently optimized
for voice search and voice
commands, so we
recommend using it
for those kinds of
use cases for now.
And then for speech
analytics, the second set
of use cases we have, that's
where the other three features
we're introducing
today are focused.
So let's talk a little
bit more about those.
So speech recognition,
for people
that are new to the space,
it sounds pretty similar.
You're trying to recognize
what someone said.
It sounds like a
consistent set of problems
that you're solving, but it can
actually be quite different.
So if you look at recognizing
a video versus recognizing
a phone call versus
recognizing a command--
an example of a video
could be a basketball game.
And you could have sounds of
the different players that
are playing, sounds of
the actual basketball
bouncing on the ground,
sounds of the TV hosts
that are sort of interrupting,
sounds of advertisements that
are playing.
And the number of speakers
could be four or more.
It could be even like
20, or 30, or 40,
depending on how many
advertisements are there.
There could be lots
of background noises,
and it could be many hours long.
If you look at phone
calls, it's usually
going to be a
handful of speakers,
and the background
there is going
to be more static from the
phone line, or compression
that's used, or a narrower
sampling rate like 8 kilohertz.
And it's usually going
to be a few minutes long.
And then if you
look at a command,
it's usually just one
speaker, a few seconds,
and there could be a
lot of background noise,
but it's very, very
different in nature.
It's going to be other
people talking, or music,
or other things playing
in the background.
A lot of Google's speech
recognition efforts
were originally focused
on the right-hand side,
on sort of voice searches
and voice commands.
But one of the kind
of top requests
we got from Cloud customers is
to solve more of the problems
on the left.
And so that's where, in April,
we introduced our new models.
So we now have four
models that you
can choose from-- phone
call, video, voice commands,
and default. And they each
are tuned to perform really
well for that set of use cases.
So voice commands is tuned
to actually filter out
all of the other
background speakers,
because it's built to
recognize one person.
And it assumes that
everything else that's
not the primary speaker
should be filtered out,
versus our phone call
model is actually
built to recognize
everyone that's
talking in the phone call
that sounds like they're
part of the conversation.
So they're kind of built
with different goals.
Now, our default model that's
been around for a year or two,
we've gotten consistent
customer feedback
that it's best in
the market, it's
better than any other
vendor that's out there.
But that was never
our aspiration.
We want it to be not just better
than others, but actually good.
And so that's where we came
out with these new models.
What we were able to do--
the video model is 64% less
errors than our default model
that was considered already
best in class in the industry.
And so you could argue that it's
three times as good as anything
else that's out there.
And then, the new
phone call model
is 54% less errors than
our previous model,
so twice as good as
what existed before.
So we're very excited about
these new models and all
of the new use cases
that they open,
because now that
you can actually
do speech recognition for these
mediums that's pretty good,
there's all of this
set of analytics
that you can do that
you couldn't do before.
So today, we're introducing two
new features in this space--
speaker that opposition and
multi-channel recognition.
So when you have a conversation
between multiple people,
our recommendation is to
record them separately
in separate channels.
And there's two
reasons for that.
One is the accuracy
of the transcription
is going to be better, because
even for humans, it's easier
to understand each
speaker separately
versus when they're talking
on top of each other.
The other reason
is it's also easier
to separate the speakers,
because you don't really need
to do anything algorithmically.
You can just figure out like
who spoke in each channel.
So for that, if you do have
the speakers separated,
that's where we were introducing
multichannel recognition that
can take an audio file
that has multiple channels
and separate the
different channels
and the speakers there.
Unfortunately, not
everyone has that luxury
of having the audio file
separated into channels.
And so if you only
have a mono channel
and you still want to
recognize multiple speakers,
that's where we're now offering,
in beta, our new speaker
diarization.
It can separate multiple
speakers in an audio file,
but it's obviously not
going to be perfect.
It's going to do kind
of a best-efforts job,
because it's using machine
learning and doing it
sort of via program versus
the external separation.
Either way, we don't recognize
the identity of the person,
and we don't store
the information
beyond the API call.
So there's nothing here
that's related to identity.
So I'm going to show
you guys just an example
architecture of how this could
be used in speech analytics.
And then we'll do a
little bit of a code lab.
And you'll also see
another example of it
later from one of
our guest speakers.
So you could imagine a setup
where you have audio coming in
from a phone gateway.
A lot of these phone gateways
were built many years ago
and don't really have the
ability to separate audio
into different channels,
so it comes out as mono.
And then, it would go
to Cloud Speech-to-Text
that does the transcription
and the diarization.
And then if you want to do
cool things, like for example
analyzing sentiment,
you really want
to analyze each
speaker separately,
because what matters is
not sort of the average
of the both, but each
one as they were talking.
So you can analyze the
customer and the agent
separately, and
then feed each one
into some analytics
engine like BigQuery,
and then run different
analytics on that data.
So last but not least, one
other feature we're introducing
is word-level confidence.
It's been kind of one
of our top features
from our ISV customers, more
sophisticated customers.
What it does, it gives
you a confidence go.
Up until now, like you
can see on the top,
we had confidence scores
that were based on segments.
Now, you actually get confidence
scores based on the words,
so you can take
more action on it,
like we prompt in the
user or things like that.
So I'm going to
show you guys how
to actually do this in Python.
Bear in mind, I'm not a
very good Python programmer.
So let's do this together.
Hopefully it will work.
If not, we'll solve it together.
Actually, before we do that,
let me just show you the sample
file that we're going to use.
So this is the sample file.
Let me play it.
I hope the audio is connected.
SPEAKER 2: Hi.
I'd like to buy a Chromecast.
I was wondering whether you
could help me with that.
SPEAKER 3: Certainly.
Which color would you like?
We have blue, black, and red.
SPEAKER 2: Let's go with black.
SPEAKER 3: Would you like a
new Chromecast Ultra model
or the regular Chromecast?
SPEAKER 2: Regular Chromecast
is fine, thank you.
SPEAKER 3: OK, sure.
Would you like to ship
it regular or express?
SPEAKER 2: Express, please.
SPEAKER 3: Terrific.
It's on the way.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you.
SPEAKER 3: Thank you very much.
Bye.
SPEAKER 1: OK, so
that's the audio file.
It's transcribing it now.
It should be done in a second.
And then, we're going
to see the results
in four different models-- so
in the default model, the phone
model, the command
model, and video.
The video model is the
best one for this file.
While it's working, what
I'm going to do next is,
I'm going to go to our docs.
And I'm going to go to the
speaker diarization example.
So it's this one here in Python.
And let's view it on GitHub.
OK, there it is.
So let's look at
video so you can
see this is the transcription.
So transcription is
reasonably accurate.
Most of the time, it's good.
Like here, you can see, or
let's go with the black one,
would you like new Chromecast
or regular Chromecast,
regular Chromecast is
fine, thank you, OK, sure.
So you can see it's
working most of the time.
So let's go to our code editor.
And we'll open this code
snippet we saw here on GitHub.
And let's try and run it.
So Python, beta
snippets, diarization--
let's see if this works.
What this should be doing is the
same thing we saw on the web,
transcribing it and
showing us the results
as well as the diarization
of the results.
And then, here it is.
So you can see there's
all of the words,
and each word has a speaker tag.
So what I want to
show you is how
to actually get a
stream of text that's
different for each speaker, and
then take that stream of text,
do some sentiment analysis,
and print the scores.
So before we do that, let's
replace the speech file with
a better one, [INAUDIBLE]
documents, code--
no, I think it's audio.
This is the name of it--
.wav.
OK, then it's going
to open the file.
Sorry, this is the wrong one.
This is transcribe
file with metadata.
Here it is, diarization.
We're going to use this file.
It's going to read the file,
then recognition config.
We don't need sample rate.
It will recognize
it automatically.
Enables diarization,
speaker count.
Let's also add
automatic punctuation.
So all we need to
do is just add this,
and it will start punctuating.
And let's also use
the video model.
So there's an
example with a model.
Let's take this and
add video model here.
OK, great.
And now, instead of printing
all the words, let's do this.
Let's do speaker1_transcript
and speaker2_transcript.
Let's initialise them.
And then, let's ask if,
basically, this thing equals 1,
then what we want to do is
take this speaker transcript
and add to it this word.
And let's also add a space.
And then, if it's the
second speaker tag,
we want to do the same thing
with a speaker2_transcript.
And then, let's do this,
let's print transcript.
And let's put in
speaker transcript 1.
And then, let's do it again
with second speaker transcript.
Transcript 2, transcript 1.
Let me save.
There's probably going to be
a bunch of compilation errors,
but let's work
through them together.
Hopefully I did the right file.
We'll see in a second.
So what we're expecting is
to see transcript 1 with all
of the words that
the first person said
and transcript 2
with all of the words
that the second person said.
OK, it looks like it's working.
So far, so good, guys.
OK, so now, let's
look at the example
for analyzing sentiment.
So this is using Cloud
Natural Language API.
I'm going to go to
this example on GitHub,
and then copy some
code lines here.
So first in terms of imports, it
needs all of this import stuff.
So let's copy it over, and
put it here on the top,
and we'll see
argparse is duplicate,
so we don't need that one.
I think we still
need the other--
oh, system 6.
Yeah, they're different.
So we have the imports.
Sorry, this is
probably too small.
Let's copy this piece that
does sentiment analysis.
And now, we'll paste it in here.
And then, we already
have a client,
so let's call this nl_client,
and nl_client here too.
And then, we don't need
this instance thing--
documents, content.
We have two different ones, so
let's call this one document1
and content equals--
how did we call it--
speaker1_transcript.
And then document2 equals
speaker2_transcript.
And then, we'll
have two sentiments.
Sentiment1 will be nl_client
analyze sentiment document1.
And then, sentiment2
will be nl_client
analyze sentiment document2.
And then, let's print sentiment
for first speaker, score
and magnitude.
And then, let's add this--
sentiment magnitude.
And I think this one
would be sentiment1.
And then, we have another
one for sentiment2--
second speaker.
OK, let's take from here all
of this stuff, paste it here.
So now, you can see
I'm not faking it.
This is real code.
OK, transcript1, transcript2,
and there's the score, guys.
This is a good example.
If I can do it, really
anyone can do it.
I really welcome you all
to try it and combine it
with whatever other
APIs you want.
And we definitely look forward
to hearing your feedback
about all these new features.
We want to make them
better over time.
So the more feedback you
can share, the better.
So with that, let
me transition over
to Nikolay from LogMeIn that's
going to take it from here.
NIKOLAY AVRIONOV: My
name is Nikolay Avrionov.
I'm the lead architect for
the GoToMeeting [INAUDIBLE]
the collaboration
products in LogMeIn.
And every month,
millions of customers
rely on our products
run their data jobs.
As you can see, we have a lot
of [INAUDIBLE] [? minutes, ?]
a lot of meetings.
And early on, we realized that
the meetings have value before
and after.
Customers need these meetings to
write notes, to reference them,
to run their business.
And what we did is, we
introduced recordings.
And after we
introduced recordings,
we started to look at how to
make these recordings even more
useful.
And the obvious step was
to add the transcription.
So we started to look for
a transcription provider,
and we selected
Google Speech-to-Text.
I'm going to talk about
what was the process that we
went through to select Google.
But first, I'm going to show
you what I have as a UI.
So after meeting,
you get this page
where you can share the
results of your meeting.
And we have a
fully searchable UI
that can search every
participant, everything
that they said,
when they said it.
You can click on certain pieces.
So you don't have to, anymore,
wait for the entire meeting
and watch it.
So let's move to a demo.
This was a meeting that Don
and I had a few weeks ago just
to go over a few things.
And so we discussed
things like a conference,
we're conferencing.
So you can see, I can find every
instance of the word conference
in the meeting.
And I can just
replay it from here,
so I don't have to
wait for that portion.
SPEAKER 4: --only in English,
and also diarization--
NIKOLAY AVRIONOV: So
we were discussing
this exact presentation.
So what was the process
for us to select
a speech-to-text provider.
We were not a Google
client at that time.
We looked at all the major
speech-to-text providers.
We built our own use cases
specifically for what we do,
because we wanted to have the
best provider for our use case.
And what we selected to
the Google Video API.
We actually started
to work with them
when the API was still in beta.
And we released our
feature one month
after the Google Video
API went into production.
So the takeaway
from here is really
test and find the best
provider for yourself.
You see these numbers
that providers usually
have accuracy, but it's
important what works for you.
How it's implemented--
before that,
we are mostly Amazon shop.
So we have our
real-time infrastructure
on Amazon or on premise.
And we have to connect our own
infrastructure with Google.
So currently, we have a
VPC between us and Google.
And we combine
several data sources.
We take all the events that
happen in the meeting--
when somebody speaks,
when he stops and starts,
the video streams, we
send the audio for Google
to transcription.
And the combined result is
what you saw on the screen.
We can identify every
speaker to a word,
and we can click on that
word and play from there.
I'm showing you a few
code samples, probably
nothing surprising for you.
One thing that we
decided is to build
a set of services--
transcription,
parsing of the
transcripts as a service.
So we can change
the transcription,
even change the
provider if we have to,
support multiple
transcription results.
So we have this layer
between us and the providers
that we can switch them
at any time if we have to.
So the code samples
are pretty easy.
One thing that I
want to emphasize
is that it's really important
to handle all the error cases,
because sometimes for
something like speech-to-text,
you can see way more
errors than something
like a regular product.
You have a recording that
nobody speaks or doesn't
start and stop really quickly.
So initially, you will
see a lot of problems
that are not problems with
the Speech-to-Text API,
but just how the
customers use the product.
We can see that the results
were really positive.
We are getting a lot on
Twitter, on other channels,
we are getting a lot of positive
feedback from customers.
We saw that the
usage of the product
is actually going
up because customers
are relying on the meeting to
be recorded and transcribed.
So sometimes they tell
us that they don't even
need to take notes anymore.
They know that this
is recorded for them,
and they just go and
review what people said.
What we're working
in the future--
we'll continue to work with Don
and his team, better accuracy
for accents.
When we started to test
it, it works very well
for native speakers.
But it really has a problem with
English with different accents,
even accents like Irish are not
transcribed as well as English.
So we are looking
forward for that.
Multi-language support,
that's obvious.
We support 16 languages, we want
to introduce all the languages
to the product.
And speaker diarization, this
is very important for us,
because a lot of meetings
happen from a conference room,
and we cannot separate
the speakers using just
our infrastructure.
We have to use the diarization.
We started to experiment,
we've been using the beta.
And again, we are applying
the same approach.
We are going to build
our own test cases,
test it, and understand
what works better for us.
Thank you, guys.
BOB MCKINNEY: How you doing?
My name is Bob McKinney.
I'm a speech analytics expert.
And I'm going to talk to you
about a really exciting project
that I've worked on
for the last year.
It's around retail.
Basically, if you've
ever worked in retail,
you understand
that retail stores
get a lot of phone calls,
from price and availability
to just checking warranty,
things like that.
So one of the projects that I've
worked on over the last year,
I worked for two national brands
working on a yearlong project.
We analyzed over
360,000 retail store
calls, which translates to about
a million minutes processed.
The goal of the project was to
focus on phone call conversion.
And this is a big deal, because
if you use AdWords or Bing
ads, or any ads out
there that have location
extensions on them,
or click to call,
or Google My Business
ads, you really
want to be able to track the
performance of those ads.
And that was the
focus of the project
to say, hey, what is the
conversion of those calls?
So using Speech-to-Text
APIs from Google,
speaker diarization
models, enhanced models,
the phone model is
the model I ended up
picking, natural language
processing for sentiment
analysis and entity analysis.
And then ultimately,
to connect it all back
to the internal system
of the two brands using
the internal
messaging bus, Google
has a pretty good version
of this, it's Pub/Sub.
But in this case, we actually
used Microsoft BizTalk.
Just a little bit about
the architecture here--
the company the partner decided
to go with for encapsulation
of the calls DialogTech,
a company out
of Chicago, great company.
Basically what happened is, a
customer would call the store,
and DialogTech
would do a post call
to a Cloud Function that would
trigger off a number of events,
one of those events
being download the wav
file from DialogTech into
the Google Cloud Storage,
which allowed you to do all
the things that Dan showed you
in the demo.
You can call that
Cloud Storage bucket
from speech-to-text,
natural language processing,
and a bunch of other places.
So we're working
through that demo.
Some of the things
we were looking
for on the output
of that in BigQuery
were fuzzy string matching,
engrams, just the frequency
of words, so demand over time.
So if a particular
product, you can
watch the demand over a
year period to say, hey,
is it ramping during this
season or that season,
or is it declining?
And that's a really big deal.
Using BigQuery, and Python, and
some of the packages in Python
allowed us to do that.
The biggest thing,
though, that helped out
the most was definitely
speaker diarization, which
allowed us to separate out the
customer from the associate
at the store.
And this allowed us
to do a lot of things,
from A/B testing on the
associate side for training,
and then engrams,
and the fuzzy text
matching on the customer side.
So we could say, hey, if
they, in this particular case,
in this call, we're
looking for phone calls
where they mention the
iPhone 7 and whether or not
it was a broken screen or
needed a battery replacement.
In this case, we wanted to
say, hey, the broken screen,
we add that to our list
for frequency for engrams.
And then, we can also go down
through that using caller ID
and match it against the
internal system using
that message bus to say, hey,
did that phone call actually
convert into a sale?
And then, if you're getting
thousands and thousands
of calls a day, you
can actually figure out
the value of those
phone calls based
on that conversion
rate, which is, I think,
pretty revolutionary.
So I encourage anybody that
has that kind of problem just
to keep working
through these APIs,
and you'll find a solution.
Some of the other things
that we could do around that
is the entity and
sentiment analysis.
So in this case, you can
see that the consumer good
being an iPhone 7, and you
could see the sentiment score is
a negative 0.4, which is
negative because they broke
the screen, they're
probably unhappy about that,
and they're just trying
to get it repaired.
And you could see that in the
entity and sentiment analysis.
Why we chose Google
Cloud to Speech?
The accuracy of
the transcription.
With phone models,
we benchmarked
against some of the major
competitors out there--
Amazon, Watson, IBM, IBM-Watson,
and the Microsoft products.
And we just found consistently
that the transcription accuracy
from the Google
Speech-to-Text, it's
significantly better than
the other options out there.
The diarization
reliability, just
being able to distinguish
between the users,
was a big deal for us--
so between the associate
and the customer.
That way, we could do
training for the associate,
and then we could do a
conversion on the customer.
Ease of use-- we had
a lot of services
already built for using
Google Cloud Services, so it
was really easy to be able
to connect them all using
a virtual private network
between the Google Cloud
Platform and the
internal network,
and connected to BigQuery
and Cloud Functions.
So all that combined
made it a no-brainer
to go with the Google Cloud
Speech-to-Text product.
So I'm going to hand
it over to Mahesh,
and he's going to talk a little
bit about what he's working on.
MAHESH BALAJI: Thanks, Bob.
I'm Mahesh Balaji.
I lead the cognitive
computing and data sciences
lab at Cognizant.
Cognizant is a leading
ID service provider,
helps clients across three
lines of services, one of which
is digital operations.
Among other things that we
do in digital operations,
we also maintain and
manage service [? text ?]
for customers, which
brings us to the case I'm
going to talk about today.
Late in Q2 of last
year, I was actually
associated with this engagement.
Client is a retail chain
based throughout the Australia
and New Zealand region.
The typical challenges were--
there was pretty high call
volumes, there was
long wait times,
primarily it's a 24
by 7 by 365 set up
where the concurrent calls
were average around 20.
Day peaks would hit
high 25s, season peaks
would hit anywhere
from 45 to 50.
So we were creating,
on an average,
75,000 tickets, unique ones.
And if you add the repeat
calls and the overlaps,
we were hitting 100K, easy.
And we had around 1,500
scenarios, or cases,
if you want to say,
that we covered
as part of this engagement.
And because of which, it took
a lot of time to onboard,
even though we bucketed common
scenarios and trained agents
accordingly.
It did take a lot
of time for us,
and attrition was not
helping the situation.
So it was fully human-dependent,
so there was a very high cost
to it.
And because of all this, our
CSAT score was pretty average.
So giving a view of the
process flow itself--
users across 3,000 stores call
in for issues like printer
cartridge not working,
the freezer is broken,
please tell me what to do.
That gets to the IVR system,
IVR system forwards that
the agent, whoever is free.
Agent listens to it, validates
the user's request first,
and then understands
the context,
and provides the response,
and the user and the agent
kind of did most
of the work there.
So fast-forwarding what we did--
we still had the human,
but he was actually
handling only the exceptions.
We replaced the whole
human handling, all of it,
with a bunch of boxes.
So now, the user calls in.
From a user perspective,
there is absolutely no change.
He still calls in a toll-free
number that still hits the IVR.
Instead of going to
the agent, it actually
goes to the integration
framework, which is the IFX,
abbreviated there.
That does the orchestration
going forward.
So we send that text to
Google Services, get the voice
clip transcribed to text,
forward that to dialogue flow,
match the intent,
get the response,
put it back into speech, and
give it back to the client.
And this flow keeps
going back and forth
until the system feels that it
has to either escalate it out
or the issues are solved.
So once we put this in
place, we immediately
saw significant benefits.
The average call time
dropped from four minutes
to one minute.
And because of that, the call
rate time came down by 20%
straight.
The human is still
there in the loop,
but he's actually
handling the exceptions.
He's not doing the
bulk of the work.
And because of that, the overall
operational cost came down.
And the quality of service
was consistent and better,
the CSAT score, by
default, jumped up.
So if I was going at 2x,
there's a clock running here,
and I don't have time.
I still have to give
you this, some Q&A time.
So that's all Dan's
problem, not mine.
And what did we
learn from all this?
I thought, this
is more important,
this is where I want
to probably spend time
than the previous context.
So don't bother
preprocessing the audio.
We went through the
exercise of doing that.
So as engineers, we
jump into the conclusion
that we have to apply
filters for noise reduction,
we have to do that, do this.
You don't have to do that.
So as a matter of fact,
it is counterproductive.
So if you apply a lot of digital
signal processing algorithms
upfront, the output
confidence score is less.
That's what we figured out.
So if you have a
proper audio clip,
send it, because
the API already does
most of that work for you guys.
And of course, the second
one was the phrase hint.
So this helped us a lot in
improving the overall score.
Given the fact that it
can take up to 500 words,
and if it's domain-specific,
it did a phenomenal job
of making sure the text
gets transcribed to the most
accuracy possible.
And the format
sampling and encoding,
I would like to add
the model also here.
Now that there's three new
models being introduced,
it's very important.
When we started off, again,
the engineering hat kind of
comes in, and we say MP4 is a
better format, it's compressed.
We kind of can move data
around quicker and all that.
But that's a lossy format.
You're better off
compromising on certain items,
and pick a lossless
format and lossless
encoding so that the output
quality, the final intention
of having the audio clip
transformed into text,
is better.
So that's what I would
actually suggest.
And I'm super excited
about the next one, which
is the word level
confidence, specifically
the case I was talking about.
So it helps big time.
Most of the
conversations are short,
and you don't have to do a
full sentence or a phrase
confidence.
You can go by the confidence
given by the word,
or you can pick and
choose the combination
to make sure the dialogue or
the conversation goes forward.
Of course, all the new
things that got introduced
does give a very, very natural
interaction between the user.
It is not IVR-ish anymore.
And that's primarily
a big difference
if you are counting the
CSAT scores and interacting.
So if you're ever
on the other side,
and if you actually get
an IVR-ish response,
I'm sure all of us hate that.
So that definitely has
come down with the new set
of models that's been
introduced by Google.